now let me get right away to the first
rule of success the first rule of
success is to have a vision
you see if you don't have a vision of
where you go and if you don't have a
goal where you go
you drift around and you never end up
anywhere
it's like you can have the best ship in
the world you can have the best airplane
in the world if the pilot or the captain
doesn't know where to go
it would just drift around it would not
end up anywhere or most likely in the
wrong place
i couldn't see myself becoming a farmer
or worker in a factory
or anything like that even though my
parents wanted me to stay there
and have a normal life my father wanted
me to become a police officer like he
was
but that was their vision not mine my
vision was totally different i felt that
i was born for something special for
something unique
for something big this is the blueprint
for my life
this is exactly what i want to do i want
to become a bodybuilding champion just
like rich park
i want to get into movies just like rich
park
and i want to make millions of dollars
and be rich and famous
just like reg park so let me tell you
something visualizing your goal and
going after it
makes it fun you got to have a purpose
no matter what you do in life
you got to have a purpose
now my second my second rule is
never ever think small if you're going
to accomplish anything you have to think
big
you have to go and shoot for the stars
the biggest challenge most people have
is because they think small
and the reason why people think small
and why they choose small
little goals is because they're afraid
to fail they know
that if you shoot for a big goal then
the chances of failing are very high
and they're afraid of failing and you
know something
that the only time you really consider
the failure is
if you fall and you don't get up but if
you get up you never consider the
failure
so i never considered myself a failure i
always considered myself a winner even
though i
fell every so often but i always got up
and i always move
forward so remember never think
small think big
[Music]
and the next thing the third point that
i'm gonna make to you is
don't listen to the naysayers
don't listen to the naysayers
everything i ever did the thing that
they heard out of people's mouth was
that's impossible that can't be done
you can't be a bodybuilding champion
that is exactly what i heard and of
course i proved to the people that it
can't be done
[Music]
so whenever someone said to me it can't
be done i heard
it can be done when they said no i heard
yes
and when they said it's impossible i
heard it is possible
if i would have listened to the
naysayers from bodybuilding to show
business to the
to politics i would not be standing here
today
talking to you i will be in austria in
the alps yodeling
that's right i will be in austria still
left yodling
that's what i will be doing exactly
so this is why i say don't listen to the
naysayers
[Music]
my fourth rule is work your ass off
nobody ever stumbled upon success by
accident i always believed
no stone unturned work your butt off
that's what i always believe no matter
what you do
work work work it doesn't matter in what
area you're in
no pain no gain the bottom line is
one of my rules which is work your butt
off
if you don't apply that rule all the
other rules won't mean anything
i believe of what ted turner said who is
one of the great entrepreneurs who
started cnn and so on
he said early to bed early to rise
work like hell and advertise so that's
what i believe
just remember you can climb that ladder
of success
with your hands in your pockets you must
work your ass off it's that simple
[Music]
my fifth and last rule is don't just
take give something back
leave your mark on the world i believe
that we all have an obligation to do
something for our community
something for our state something for
our country
we must serve a cause that is greater
than ourselves
because we all know that on the end we
will be judged
not by how much we made but how much we
give
every single time i reached out and i
gave something back i felt fantastic
nothing made me happier i would rather
play chess with an eight-year-old kid in
an after-school program
or play golf a round of golf with a
special olympian
then go down another red carpet of a
movie premiere and have nothing against
movies
but to give something back to me is more
important than just to think about
myself
so i feel very strongly all of us need
to have
and embrace that kind of a spirit
we all can create change whether it is
in our neighborhood
or in our local schools or in our
country it can be big but it can also be
as little as just going to a school kid
that has problems reading and teaching
that kids how to read
or how to do math we don't have to just
work on
me we should also work on we
not just me but also we remember that
to lead a truly full life you must give
back
you must leave the world a better place
than you found it
[Music]
you